OK. Let's get down to business.
First, I'd like to welcome everybody to today's meeting.
Jeff sends his apologies for his absence from today's meeting.
His son is sick.
The objective of our meeting today is to brainstorm ideas for more effective sales techniques.
That is our target this afternoon.
I have a few ideas I'd like to share first,...
...and then we will go around the table and hear other ideas from each person here today.
We'll try to keep to ten minutes for the discussion of each idea.
That way the meeting won't run too long.
And I've asked Karen to take minutes for the meeting.
So, as background I'd just like to take you...
...through the standard sales techniques used in our department.